من عالم الاخبار الى عالم الانشاد الديني
ودعنا الليله ضيف مميز هو المنشد التركي
مسعود كارلس ينضم الينا من العاصمه
المقدونيه اهلا وسهلا بك مسعود
وشكرا على حضورك معنا بدايه ماذا تفعل في
مقدونيا
اولا اريد ان اسلم عليكم جميعا واطيب
التحيه للجميع المشاهدين وانا في مدينتي
الذي اعيش واسكن في عاصمه مقدونيا طبعا
نحن في بدايه
اول يوم شهر رمضان اول يوم للصيام والحمد
لله مبسوطين جدا ومسرورين لاننا قد نرى
التغيير في الجو هنا في مقدونيا وفي كما
عندكم في قطر وفي عالم الجميع اينما
يعيشون اخوتنا المسلمون الحمد لله
واتمنى ان انتم ايضا ان تكونوا بخير ان
شاء الله الحمد لله نحن بخير وشكرا على
مشاعرك الطيبه وكل عام وانت بخير نسيت ان
ابدا معك بذلك لكن حينما نتحدث عن مسعود
نتحدث عن منشد
تركي هل هل هذا التوصيف هو التوصيف الذي
تحبه لنفسك ام انك تعتبر نفسك
مطربا ومن ضمن ما تطرب الناس به هو
الانشاد الديني
طبعا
منذ بدايه في
الانشاد اقوله والاغاني الهادفه الدينيه
بعضهم يسمون دينيه وبعضهم يسمون اغاني
الهادفه بالنسبه لي ليست
هذه
المهم المهم هو ماذا نقدم للجميع
للمستمعين هناك طبعا الذي انا اركز اكثر
شيء في
اناشيد
القديمه التراث من التراث واحاول ان اعمل
بالتوزيع الجديد ان اقدم
للجمهور وايضا هناك من الحاني وهناك من
ايضا الاغاني الجديده الذي الف من قبل
الشعراء المعروفين عند العرب وعند الاتراك
وعندنا في بلدنا وايضا مع الموزعين
الجيدين ونحاول ان نقدم اشياء ايضا جديده
طبعا
بطريقه معاصره
باصوات ايضا
بالالات
الغربيه والشرقيه نعمل نحاول ان نعمل ايضا
كيف يقولون
الاشياء نؤتي الامثله من الطرفين الغربي
والشرقي وطبعا هو حتى الكثير من الناس
يقولون تركي مماكدونيا وطبعا لازم تعرفون
اكمل اكمل هذه الفكره
نعم استطيع ان اقول ان هنا في من يعيش في
كثير من يتكلم يتحدث التركيه واللغه
التركيه ايضا معروف عند الجمهور المقدوني
وايضا انا من ناحيه الام
في الالبانيه ايضا
نطقن هنا البانيه ايضا
من اصول البان لكن نتقن اللغه التركيه
وطبعا هذا ليست ايضا بمهم نحن المواطنين
العالميين كما يقولون اننا نحن في كل
الدول العربيه تتقابل مع الجماهير العرب
في الشرق مع الاندونيسيين والماليزيين
وطبعا تعلمت في مدرسه الثانويه في مدرسه
اصابه هنا في مدرسه في البدايه ولكن ايضا
بعد هذا درست في بريطانيا في جامعه
لامبيتر وفي معهد الاوروبي
الشريعه
ايضا هناك مع الاساتذه العرب في
وهذا ساعدتني كثيرا ان اقدم فني باللغه
العربيه
كلغه الثانيه
او الثالثه ذكرت التراث
ومن امتع الاغاني التي استمعت اليك فيها
هي البرده
للامام البوصيري وكما تعلم الامام
البوصيري صعيدي مصري من اسيوط
لو لو تسمعنا هذه الاغنيه هذه البرده
عزيزه على نفس الكثيرين
اوكي اذن ننشد مقطع اتفضل
محمد
سيد الكونين
والثقل
محمد سيد الكونين
والساقين
مولاي صلي وسلم
من ابدا على
حبيبك خير الخلق
كله وهو الحبيب الذي ترجى شفاعه
هو الحبيب الذي ترجى شفاعه
مولاي صلي وسلم دائما
ابدا على
خلقه
الله الله وهذا لحنك هذا لحنك انت مسعود
عندنا في ماكدونا ننشد بالالحان مختلفه
لكن طبعا هذا من لحن التراث الهندي عندما
كنت انا في بريطانيا سمعت من الهنود ومن
الباكستانيين وعندما قمت بالبوم الاول في
الصلوات في سنه 2004 نزلنا هذه الاغنيه
وبعد 18 سنه قد عملنا توزيع الجديد وصورنا
الميوزك فيديو الثاني لنفس القصيده قصيده
البرده والجمهور الذي يتابعونني يعرفون
جيدا جدا عن هذه الاغنيه وعن التوزيع
الجديد طبعا نحن في رمضان وكل مره نحن
نحاول نقدم اشياء جديده وغدا عندي
الانشوده جديده مع منشد وقارئ معروف
ابراهيم الدردساوي قمنا بعمل وسمينا
الانشوده باسم قران قران وتصوير قد تمت في
امريكا
وبعد هدف في اسطنبول قد انتهينا بالتصوير
وغدا ان شاء الله سوف يكون النزول ايضا
لهذه الانشوده الجديده وما في احد ولا
الان
ما سمعوا هذه الاسود وغدا ان شاء الله
سيكون النزول وانا سعيد جدا وفرحان جدا
لماذا لا تساعدنا ايضا بسماع مقطع من هذه
الانشوده
والله اوكي فقد احول المقطع لان ما نزل ما
نزل نقول هكذا
قران قران
[موسيقى]
هكذا الاغنيه قران قران
الكلمات غير معروفه الى الان لكن ان شاء
الله سيكون النزول غدا باذن الله طيب نطلب
منك اغنيه اخرى انا سمعت لك اغنيه عن
رمضان
ثانيه استطيع ان اقدم
يعني انا لا اريد ان عليك حتى انشوده يا
رمضان ايوه هذه نريد ان اسمعها لو هي
جاهزه معك
نعم
ان لوصالك يا رمضان
للتوبه والغفران
ومجالسه القران ضم
ان ظن ومجالسه القران نور في الافق يلوح
باب
الجنه الا باب الريان
في الافق يلوح باب الجنه مفتوح لا
يروي شروح الا باب الريان ضمان
ومجانسه القران ضم
امان
ومجالسه القران
الله الله جميل يعني
للاسف يعني
اقتربنا من النهايه لكن اريد ان اكون لك
سؤالا اخيرا فيما يتعلق بالمشاهدات لانه
انا شاهدت بعض اغانيك يشاهدها على
اليوتيوب فقط
عشرات الملايين هل هذا عامل يدخل في
اعتبارك حينما تختار نشيدا او اغنيه ام
انك تغني وتشعر بما تشعر به وليشاهد من
يشاهد والسلام
والله منذ بدايهنا يعني عندما نخطط
الالبوم وننزل الالبوم
من اهميه دائما اركز ان اقدم اشياء الذي
ارى لان في تراثنا الاسلاميه في الكلمات
الطيبه والحان الطيب الذي انا احس ان في
لازم ان نقدم للجيل الجديد الذي ما سمعوا
ولا كلمه او ولا دندنه ولا واحد من قبل
هذا الذي
لا يهمني بكثير لان هناك في اشياء في
اناشيد مثلا من ينجح وفي يناشيد الذي لا
ينجح لكن هذا لا يعني ان ليست هذه
الانشوده ناجحا بل هناك نرى الجماهير من
يتابعوننا جيدا قد
يستمعون واحيانا في حفلاتنا يطلبون اناشيد
الذي مشتهر كثيرا لكن مازال هناك في
الجمهور معينه من يتابع ويهتم بهذه القيم
نشيدا ليس مشهورا لكن احبه وهو عن التوبه
ان نقدم اشياء نعم لكن للاسف انتهى وقتنا
مسعود
المنشد التركي ضيفنا من العاصمه المقدونيه
سكوبي شكرا جزيلا لك